Kylie Jenner hints she's opening a Kylie
cosmetics store didn't contemplating
going back to her roots while sister
Kendall and mom Kris are spreading the
word to get out and vote against
Kourtney Kardashian's revealing secrets
about her and Kim daughters so you're
the go-to these days for everything
beauty fashion makeup it's really
exciting to watch I bet you're having a
ball I'm having so much fun I feel like
I'm getting into so many cool beauty
things I'm excited about it I mean stuff
like you're genuinely passionate ya can
tell yes and now that passion may be
getting the brick-and-mortar treatment
Kylie shared these pics from inside an
under-construction storefront she
captioned one shot soon Kylie cosmetics
and the other my vision I can't wait for
you guys to see what goes on inside my
mind and what I've been working on a
hundred percent Kylie it's gonna be cool
the newly blonde star also posted these
throwbacks with her dark hair asking her
fans should I go back meanwhile Kylie's
mom and sister share different pics both
urging their followers to get out and
rock the vote for Hillary Clinton and
Kourtney Kardashian is talking her and
Kim's kids on Britain's this morning
Penelope is into makeup and beauty I
think just from seeing me and my mom got
Penelope and North these little vanities
for Christmas with all you know filled
it with like makeup and I try to get
them as much natural makeup products as
possible but I love to let them
experiment and play and just have fun
with it
you